su su su su su su su su su su ed a tutti
i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo su primi
venti ragazzi questo è un indie games
fatto con l'olio ritiene già in che mi
ha colpito me l'avete consegnato in
tantissimi e mi ha colpito un casino per
una cosa in particolare che adesso
vedrete c'è una cosa etica che figo
ragazzi non ho praticamente vi spiego il
suo gioco il tempo si ferma quando tutti
fermi c'è una cosa impressionante non so
come cazzo gli è venuto in mente con che
grazie per gli occhiali fratello li
metto subito comunque si ragazzi in
poche parole qui il tempo scorre società
use only when you move niente c'è
scritto il tempo scorre soltanto se ti
muovi e io veramente non so chi ha avuto
quest'idea me fantastico c'è una cosa
del genere
taking da un buttano giù ragazzi voi non
sapete come ricevere un calcio nelle
vigne da pa vj ma vi posso assicurare
che non è per niente piacevole mio zio
l'ho massacrato sceglie lo fate entrare
nei polmoni non lo so perfetto ragazzi
adesso leonardo sono armato e pericoloso
e poi non averti è quello no ragazzi
qualcuno mi spiega che il cazzo sono 62
kill the mall uccidi di tutti sta
sparando una mista becca figlia che mira
di merda childs io ragazzi aspettate da
farlo alzare troppo la matrix
ovviamente ragazzi era soltanto di
allenamento adesso ci riprova questa è
seria con questo non mi sta cagando di
striscia e lurido stronzo sono quei
piacere province di cemento ragazzi mai
guardarmi con con gli occhiali da soli
più brutti dei miei e prima andato
ragazzo v'è secondo dov'è quell'unico
brutto stronzo non credere di riuscire a
colpirmi perché sono meglio di noi
altro che matrix mio zio mi chiama ci
hai dato dentro ieri su youtube si
vedono gli effetti non si vede più un
cazzo amico mio non mi prende un metro
più allora hai usato quello ieri sera
per ridurti così benissimo di giogiò
vista jingle ragazzi e non scherzate
consolle dj perché vi ritrovate senza
birillo altro posto gioco next level
deal is of chi è quel tizio dovrà
accogliere la pistola al volo ma con dio
ci provo quando si muore muore ma rende
tutti ragazzi vi trovai così sento
pronto ai modo of it i colpi ma chi se
ne frega sono pieno di armi dove siete
ragazzi ancora qualcuno clinici ai vip
la stanza dei vip ci sono soltanto io
sono l'unico vip dista zona benissimo
muore ragazzi vip vincono sempre vincono
sempre dove
am j voglio quella di riguarda allora
sei bastardo non si spara e di vai così
marco al capitano impossibile di
riscattare le migliori devi morire lo
zio non muore
allora lo vedi questo in proiettile te
lo fai ficcare nel cervello bene così
hp ce vole un po ma lo capisce alla fine
perfetto
fuori anche tu muori anche quando
ragazzi ma vi dovete impegnare per far
così schifo è all gone cazzo o fisico e
più vecchia ti sto pistola in testa le
pistole in testa non uccidono
ricordatevelo ragazzi devono aggiungere
un'altra pista la prima che mi spari non
so come cazzo alla spesa che ci provo
ragazzi già sto facendo non so come ma
che schivata ce la posso fare
posso fare no maledizione sono quasi
porca [ __ ] che ho fatto una cosa epica
oddio che è cool as unica come lo
sfigato allora due sono andati sputa
altra gente ma quanti siete
mio dio c'è il mondo supporto vice di
alzare che un sua leggera grazie ho
vinto non si sa come ma ho vinto sa bene
cos'è ragazzi ormai in un telo più
nessuno sono troppo forte il greg crepe
degan annuncio non ci devo raggiungere
l'arma prima che mi ammazzino michael
bay un cast ora che è impossibile non
troppo lontana come cazzo faccio come
calcio tra i vari il possibile sono in
40 a spararmi mio dio
oddio ho saltato ho saltato un
proiettile adesso la mia vita è
fottutamente completa ho fatto tutto
tutto quello che desidera sì ci sono ci
sono ci sono
porca [ __ ] ma allora vaffan mi sono
rotto il gatto alle sparate a [ __ ]
che ne so io ci si può nascondere nelle
colonne e ditelo prima racconta la
strage la strage la strage non ci credo
non ci voglio credere
no non ci credo
biggar ok devo prendere a elia li l'arma
devo raggiungere mi stanno sparando in
tre
l'universo sono [ __ ] suppa dei comic
loro continuano ad arrivare a me non me
ne frega un cazzo perché sono troppo
forte dammi l'arma a luglio maraga qua
devo fare una strage peccioli chuck
norris credo aspetta un attimo si
rimanda cos'è chiari trolling isan art
sono finti sono finti ragazzi mi hanno
preso per il culo non vi azzardate
ho riletto e tutti non avete il diritto
di farlo non ragazzino theo fare una
strage che non possono trovarmi non ne
hanno diritto
fuori rete tutti e tutte assistere dal
massacro più top dove sono dove siete
venite qui ma le venidte equivale a in
auto fanno o finiti kobe cazzo ragazzi
ok non finite ma i colpi davanti a un
nemico prima regola
ho trovato un'altra pistola non so dove
ma va bene così e gioielli zio siamo
quasi up perfetto tra le banche o uno
non so dove mamma l'ho uccisa io ti
troverò è più però mancato mancato
mancato ancora zio mancato affioravano
bosco velo
il gioco amico mio vuole con qualcuno tu
motocross come te gioco per lei loco
pertuso rella dove siete stronzi fatevi
vedere la tv vai scherzare non è morto è
mancato mi sono fatta mancano tre minuti
è possibile è vecchio dentro ragazzi
sono super boss fight ragazzi c'è la
battaglia col vostro devo presentarmi il
più cazzuto possibile quindi direi che
ci siamo ragazzi devo fargli il culo non
so chi è il vero ucci ucci di il seo che
chiesero 6 tuo amico mio 66 kg ma devo
devo ucciderti cazzo sei proprio forte
c'è mio dio è il boss più difficile che
abbia mai battuto in tutta la mia vita
[ __ ] di troppo vince chi sei tu
chiara questo ragazzo è spuntato un
tizio non me lo sono immaginato non vedo
un cazzo con gli occhiali che è che
cazzo era quello non c'è di che amico
dovere di fuochi j
dov'è allora innanzitutto ticali perché
sono un calcio nei [ __ ] anche ha
tenuto lo toglie nessuno va bene dove
dove sei tizio e ti vengo a prendere a
schiaffi un po anche a te perché nei
bisogno dov'è
devo camminare attraverso la finestra ma
non vi siciliano mai giù dalla piena
adottati tuo cerebroleso non io ma [ __ ]
questo vuole che mi suicidi ma questo
non ha capito niente
don't be a cloud non essere un codardo
ma la tua sorella un codardo ma
[ __ ] get back noi non torni
indietro non nessuno mi dare gli ordini
però mi sa che sono mi butto giù ragazzi
non la finisco più quindi lo faccio
[Musica]
questa era la scena di matrix che ho
invitato malissimo
[Musica]
shipp cappotto ragazzi che cazzo
successo sono fatte a fermarmi noi come
si va avanti di qua easy di and ragazzi
ho finito super hot ma veramente come
gioca un concetto epico io non ho mai
visto gioco del genere perché ne faranno
uscire un altro prima o poi perché
veramente non lo so è fantastico e lo
farò di sicuro perché digiuno epico
comunque ragazzi di sei video è piaciuto
lasciate un commento vi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come ogni video
trovate nella descrizione sensi di chi
ti scrive the lady ci vediamo in un
prossimo futuro